der vertrieb ist lässt sich einfach von
unserem hund ziehen hier wird mein name
ist luca und sorry das ist ein wenig
verschlafen aus sehr aber ich bin ein
bisschen verschlafen ihr seht schon
ungewohnte kulisse ich bin nämlich
gerade im urlaub aber am heutigen video
geht es darum dass ich euch auf twitter
gesagt habt ihr sollten wir fragen
stellen zum thema real talk also ernste
fragen und da ich schon seit gefühlten
jahren kein faq mehr aufgeladen habe
kommt das heute wir fangen an
kannst du deine krankheit eigentlich
auch irgendwie loswerden bei der frage
geht es glaube ich um die panikattacken
wozu ich damals ein video hochgeladen
habe vor einem halben jahr das lustige
was heißt es lustige das hat tatsächlich
alles hier angefangen im schnee oder mit
meiner familie hat sich letztes jahr
hier war habe ich halt noch studiert und
das waren gerade die letzten monate
meines studiums das heißt sie hatte
schon zweieinhalb jahre voller stress
hinter mir also die kombination studium
klausuren praktikum youtube und sehr
sehr wenig schlaf aber trotzdem viel
party also bei mir dazu geführt dass ich
herzrasen bekommen hatte atemnot und
seitdem so nicht ja so kern gesund bin
ich weiß nicht ob man das irgendwie mit
einem burnout vergleichen kann oder ja
so ein holiday heart syndrom oder
irgendwie sowas hatte der arzt damals
gesagt aber um auf die frage
zurückzukommen nein ich kann das
eigentlich nicht wirklich loswerden das
ganze zeit eine kopfsache also ich bin
man also ich bin komplett kerngesund ich
habe ja ekg gemacht hohe belastungs-ekg
ist verschiedene tests blutabnahme
terrasse oder alles kontrolliert ich bin
topfit aber es ist eine sache der psyche
und der kopf sagt dass man krank sei
hört sich total bescheuert an ich weiß
aber es ist wirklich so immer wenn ich
viel stress hatte wenig geschlafen habe
dann vielleicht auch in der kombination
mit alkohol das ist dann am nächsten tag
wirklich herzrasen habe und mich unwohl
fühle und so ein bisschen unruhig bin
und nervös die ganze zeit also ich kann
es nicht so richtig los ich hab sogar
ein buch dabei dass sie hatte mir damals
sogar ein fan geschenkt auf dem
fantreffen und meinte luca hier
meine mutter hatte das auch hier ist das
buch und da bin ich gerade dabei das
durchzulesen also die angst aus heiterem
himmel panikattacken und wie man sie
überwinden kann also man kann das ganze
nicht komplett loswerden man kann das
jetzt nicht einfach so ablegen die
beispielsweise auch ich bin gerade
erkältet ich nehme ein paar medikamente
und ernähre mich gesund und tue mir ruhe
anderen bin ich einer woche wieder fit
oder so so ist das alles hat nicht aber
wenn man gab eine panikattacke hat kann
man sich darauf vorbereiten dass man die
relativ schnell weg kriegt in welchem
online shop gibt es die besten klamotten
bis zwar keine realtiv frage aber hey da
also nicht da der der shop
wir haben jetzt übrigens auch gutscheine
im shop das heißt sie können einfach auf
den shop gehen oder eure eltern und wenn
ihr eure eltern nicht wissen okay was
möchte sich meine tochter mein sohn
eigentlich genau kaufen aber sie
wünschen sich was aus dem shop aber
wissen nicht genau was können sie auch
gutschein kaufen und dann kann die den
gutschein einlösen und die sind
unendlich lang haltbar also könnt euch
auch jetzt ein gutschein kaufen und in
zwei jahren irgendwie was kaufen hast du
manchmal das gefühl dass dein leben so
von youtube eingenommen ist dass du dich
privat davon eingeengt fühlt ich bin mir
nicht so ganz sicher was mit der frage
gemeint ist also ich weiß nicht wie ich
mich privater von eingeengt fühlen kann
aber was ich auf jeden fall sagen kann
ist dass ich mein privatleben auf jeden
fall anders gestaltet seitdem ich
youtube mache also ich gehe einfach nie
mehr in die innenstadt so wirklich weil
ich einfach nicht möchte dass wirklich
alle paar sekunden leute irgendwie einen
in die höhe so angucken dafür dass ich
will keine ahnung was da wird ja
irgendwie angeguckt wie ein tier im zoo
oder so also ich gestalte auf jeden fall
mein privatleben so ein bisschen anders
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass dadurch
eingeengt bin dass ich mache eigentlich
genau die gleichen sachen wie früher
auch nur ich achte so ein bisschen mehr
darauf dass das ganze ich glaube das was
meine wenn du eine freundin hätte ist
ich will jetzt keine hoffnung machen du
stinkst nämlich so doll würdest du uns
hashtag der lubu davon erzählen und wenn
nein warum ich hatte bis vor circa einem
jahr eine freundin
über fasten jahr und da habe ich nicht
erzählt und es hat auch keiner so
wirklich rausgefunden aber ich denke
wenn ich jetzt befreundet haben würde
würde ich schon sagen also ja keine
ahnung ich glaube es kommt immer so ein
bisschen auf die situation und willst du
dich jetzt auf youtube konzentrieren
oder die einen job suchen ich glaube mit
dem jetzt meint sie weil ich vor einigen
wochen meinen bachelor erfolgreich
abgeschlossen hat nochmal applaus
ich konnte mich auf jeden fall jetzt
seit einigen wochen nur auf youtube und
merke auch dass das mega gut läuft also
ich mache mir viel mehr gedanken bei
videos machen andere formate bei denen
ich ein bisschen mehr arbeit reinstecken
obwohl man sich eigentlich nicht mal
immer noch genau die gleiche scheiße
aber mein plan für die zukunft ist auf
jeden fall erstmal noch ein bisschen
youtube machen und dann eventuell ab
märz oder spätestens im sommer dann ein
master studien zu machen studium
wie finde ich heraus welcher studiengang
für mich der richtige ist ich habe es
damals durch praktikas und solche
aktionen wie es juden for one day
rausgefunden also durch praktika habe
ich beispielsweise einfach erfahren dass
ich diese sachen nie machen möchte zum
beispiel mal ein praktikum in der
elektro in einem elektrofachgeschäft
gemacht als elektro fachhandels
verkäufer kaufmann keine ahnung was das
hat mir überhaupt gar keinen spaß
gemacht wusste ich dass ich sowas
einfach nie studieren möchte aber dann
habe ich als das team von davy 23 mal in
düsseldorf gemacht und auch einmal in
köln und weil ich halt immer auf jeden
fall in nrw da am rhein sein wollte
deshalb so eineinhalb stunden von
bielefeld entfernt davon zu hause aber
andererseits bin ich auch so ein
bisschen weg von zu hause aber ich würde
auf jeden fall jugend voran day machen
das kann man eigentlich überall machen
und zwar sucht ihr euch einfach in den
studiengang haus dann setzt euch einfach
mal tag lang bei denen die vorlesungen
und dann seht ihr direkt okay das macht
mir spaß oder nicht warum bist du so
herzlich danke auch auf jeden fall an
die erste frage du hast einen kommentar
bei closing luca auf insta gelassen der
für die person schon etwas verletzend
war kannst du dazu stellung nehmen oder
beziehungsweise darüber was sagen
blöding luca ist eine sache die ich vor
einigen wochen auf instagram entdeckt
habe und zwar ich dachte mir das gibt's
sofort so fashion leuten oder so aber es
ist eine userin die auch teil der luke
schule ist also sie ist jetzt kein hater
oder keine ahnung irgendwie was also sie
ist auch schon teil der luke schuhe und
so und sie ist auch mega projekt also
ich lese ja auch teilweise ihre
kommentare und so aber ich kurz zu
erklären was es überhaupt ist floating
luca das ist eine instagram seite wo sie
täglich oder nahezu täglich einfach
styles von mir hochlädt also was ich für
klamotten trage für accessoires und so
bin ich an sich eigentlich ganz cool
weil dadurch leute die mich sehen und
vielleicht cool finden dass ich jetzt
gerade ein weißes t shirt für drei euro
an habe leute die sich dann fragen hey
wort luca eigentlich dass das
kleidungsstück her die können auf die
seite gehen und sehen dann hat dieses
weiße t-shirt aus dem müll oder
irgendwie so und dann steht da der preis
bayern das sage ich als eine ganz gute
idee allerdings ist mehr als jedes
zweite bild auf dieser instagram seite
einfach falsch also das ist dann einfach
irgend alternative oder irgendwas was
ich nicht an habe oder wirklich was
komplett anderes ein ganz anderes
t-shirt und da denke ich mir dann oft so
hell dann macht das ganze eigentlich
überhaupt keinen sinn vor allem wenn
dann irgendwie meine uhr da hochgeladen
wird und dann wird da gesagt dass das
mit 10.000 euro rolex ist sündig geht so
ein bisschen sobald die idee an sich ist
ganz cool aber ich will jetzt auch nicht
ganz so lange drüber lover an der
kommentare auch überhaupt nicht böse
gemeint wünschst du dir manchmal einen
anderen beruf zu haben mit dem du nicht
in der öffentlichkeit stehen würde ist
ja jeden tag eigentlich klappt schon auf
ihren videos gesagt ich bräuchte ein
bisschen dass ich mich auf youtube
gezeigt habe weil ich quasi kein
richtiges öffentliches leben mehr führen
kann weil ich jetzt die blumen das ist
ein neues riesiges kaufhaus im video
feld unterwegs und da haben halt immer
so leute irgendwie geguckt und
irgendwann weiter im buchladen um
geschenke von meiner eltern einzukaufen
und dann kamen wirklich so 30 leute an
und der ganze buchladen hat mich
angeguckt ein buchladen kann nicht
gucken luca oder wenn man dann eine
clubs feiern ist und mit freunden und so
und dann gucken da dann irgendwie alle
leute an und dann auf einmal wenn man
dann irgendwie richtig abgeht dann sieht
man plötzlich von der seite oder
irgendwie das ist halt ein bisschen
anstrengend so was geht bei fans würdig
zu weit beziehungsweise was magst du ein
fan pages und was nicht wie gott schon
gesagt was ich finde was so ein bisschen
zu weit geht ist halt einfach wenn die
privatsphäre überschritten wird
natürlich wenn man mich jetzt irgendwo
auf der straße sieht oder im club oder
im kaufhaus oder keine ahnung wo dann
kann man mich natürlich ansprechen und
ich mache auch mit jedem in meinem foto
aber zum beispiel letztens war ich mit
einem kollegen von mir wir haben so ein
paar sachen eingekauft und sind dann
nachher mit dem auto die ausfahrt lang
gefahren unterstand wirklich so ein fan
mit einer spiegelreflexkamera und hatte
plötzlich die ganze zeit mein auto
fotografiert und uns und das war der
erste moment wo ich meiner kompletten
youtube karriere wirklich ausgelastet
werden ich habe wirklich neben ihm
angehalten bin ausgestiegen die autos
sind haben wir dachten auch schon sehr
was macht er jetzt willst du den
tübinger gesagt egal du darfst du diese
bilder von mir machen also ich habe ja
kein recht mehr in meinem eigenen bild
wenn die person des öffentlichen lebens
und man darf mich fotografieren in alle
möglichen lagen und dabei bleibe aber
ich habe ihm gesagt mega deal erst jetzt
alle bilder weil das geht einfach safe
zu weil es vor allem war er dann auch
noch vom wixxer und dann gesagt so ja
hier kann man jetzt habe ich die bilder
gelöscht nicht sehr zeigt man
aufeinander
bilder geht so weiter hat daneben noch
drei vier mal andere aus fotografiert
und dann noch mal in die zehnmal mich so
oder dachte ich einfach nur so edita
witz nicht verarschen sowas geht meiner
meinung nach zu weit
es gab auch schon sehr häufig
situationen das einfach
essenslieferanten mein aidoo bist doch
dieser youtuber kannst mal für meine
tochter hierbleiben sticker und so also
solche sachen gehen einfach zu weit wenn
die privatsphäre verletzt wie zum
beispiel bei meiner eltern stehen auch
von häufig leute vor der tür und das mag
ich einfach nicht so warum machst du
keine let's play mehr youtube hat den
slogan broadcast yourself das heißt man
soll irgendwas hochladen was einem
selbst gefällt was man machen möchte und
das mache ich
und der zeit habe ich halt nicht so
krass lust auf let's play außerdem mache
ich doch jetzt place also ich mach jetzt
keine reinigen die minecraft part 400
oder happy meals part 770 oder irgendwie
so was aber heißt so sachen wie akinator
clever bord holte er luft das sind ja
sind ja auch let's play was war das
krasseste was ein verein beziehungsweise
zuschauer je getan hat also ich weiß
nicht was sie mit das krasseste meint
aber was ich zum beispiel mal sehr krass
fand war in hamburg auf dem
jungfernstieg da hat einen fernen foto
mit mir gemacht und selbst dabei sein
handy fallen lassen weil da irgendwie
gezittert hat und dabei ist ein weniger
butt gehört sage ich gar nicht lustig
wir wollten auch schon mal feiern gehen
und der türsteher nicht so zur seite
gezogen ich dachte an ein als wenn ich
jetzt nicht reinkommen
wir machen jetzt erst mal ein foto der
kante dann halten wir auch einen
youtube-kanal dass ich auch mal krass
fand war als einvernehmlich gefragt hat
haye kam ein bild machen wie du mich auf
den mund küsst er habe ich nicht gemacht
haben freunde von dir die schon mal
ausgenutzt dafür dass du bekannt ist und
dass er später gemerkt ich glaube nicht
also ich habe eigentlich ganz gutes
gespür dafür auch freunde wirklich
freunde sind oder nur leute die einen
irgendwie aufgrund von bekanntheit oder
irgendwas anderem ausnutzen wollen
also wenn schon früher als ich noch in
der schule war da gab es ein paar leute
die dann 40 jahre lang nichts mehr
gehört von dir aber zum beispiel hat sie
nach köln gezogen bin habe ich die
ersten zwei monate während meines
studiums einfach gar nicht gesagt dass
ich gut mache und dann wurde irgendwann
mal in der bar erkannt oder kam also
direkt an das was machst du da ein
bisschen fußball oder irgendwie so war
wir halt einfach wichtig um
herauszufinden ob die leute auch so mit
mir befreundet sein würden also unsere
clique und das war halt auch der fall
und wir unterhalten zum beispiel bei
youtube und die leute mit denen ich
derzeit so kraft befreundet bin zum
beispiel finden könnt ihr auch den kenne
ich seit zwölf jahren
da habe ich nicht mal youtube gemacht
hast du große ziel oder wünsche für 2018
ich möchte mir auf meinen körper hören
und wir mehr ruhe antun
hört sich voll besteuert einmal alle
anderen eigentlich mal sagen ich will
richtig durchziehen und herstellen wie
zufrieden bist du momentan mit einer
situation auf youtube ich bin ultra
zufrieden also ich glaube ich war noch
nicht zufrieden mit meiner ganzen
youtube laufbahn
weil der zeit habe ich einfach mit den
leuten kontakt mit denen ich kontakt
haben möchte ich kann videos drehen mit
den leuten mit denen videos drehen
möchte ich kann genau das hochladen was
ich auch wirklich hochladen möchte
worauf ich bock habe ich habe mich
letztens mit anderen youtube-kanäle
unterhalten die gaming machen und weil
denen wirklich gesagt wir werden die
real life machen oder was anders dann
sagen die fenster denkbar
wir wollen gaming gesehen bei mir ist es
halt so wenn ich so etwas mache dann
feiert ihr das wenn ich auf videos von
euch reagiere bei luca reagiert dann
fällt ihr das wenn ich gerne mache dann
fällt ihr das also ich bin mega dankbar
und mega zufrieden mit der situation
gerade findest du es eigentlich nervig
wenn jemand dich trifft und ich nur
sachen über youtube rad oder ist das
eher normal wenn ich leute treffe mit
denen ich nicht so richtig befreundet
bin und die beispielsweise zum ersten
mal sehe und die dann wissen heja oder
als youtuber dann kommen natürlich
direkt erst mal 40 fragen dazu und das
fakt schon ultra aber wenn ich so mit
meinen kollegen unterwegs bilden oder
mit älteren engeren freunden dann ist
überhaupt kein thema das mega entspannt
dass das man nicht besprochen wird dann
was würdest du machen wenn man dich rein
theoretisch als dj für eine
geburtstagsparty haben wollen würde hier
eventuell wisla dich auf soundmix selbst
hoch ich habe seit wochen kann es
hochgeladen werde es auf jeden fall auch
bald auf youtube tun weil wir jetzt
derzeit einige rechte gerade einholen an
liedern die ich zusammen mixen kann
allerdings würde ich um auf die frage
zurückzukommen einfach absagen
der vertrieb ist lässt sich einfach für
unseren hund ziehen
aber ich möchte auch allgemein erst
auflegen wenn ich wirklich eigene tracks
produziert habe also vielleicht bald
irgendwann dafür ist jetzt ihr vom video
meine damen und herren ich wollte
einfach mal so ein bisschen wie ad hoc
ernst aber ein paar team reden so dass
ihr mich eventuell bisserl besser
kennenlernen wenn es euch gefallen hat
das gern mal leid da wenn ihr meint dass
ich das öfter hochladen soll rund sonst
würde ich sagen die nächsten tage kommen
auf jeden fall auch videos ich bin zwar
im urlaub aber ich habe auf jeden fall
vielleicht ich vorproduziert und schau